des informations marquantes de ce début
de semaine le milliardaire américain
elon musk l'homme le plus riche du monde
qui rachète le réseau social twitter
prix d'achat 44 milliards de dollars
pour une entreprise qui n'est pas
rentable on se demande pourquoi nicolas
fleury
c'est une transaction qui donnent le
vertige
41 milliards d'euros voilà la somme
déboursée par elon musk pour acheter le
réseau social twitter
un montant à la hauteur de la fortune de
l'homme le plus riche du monde malgré
ces 200 millions d'utilisateurs
l'entreprise est déficitaire mais pour
le milliardaire américain ce réseau
scrutées par les journalistes investi
par les politiques sera surtout un outil
d'influencé un média aussi puissants aux
mains d'une seule personne
certains s'en inquiètent car dans ces
entreprises l'homme d'affaires réputé
imprévisible décide seul de paypal qu'il
développe avec succès dans les années 90
jusqu'à tesla et space x il fait fortune
avec des projets parfois digne de la
science fiction
on peut apporter sur mars la vie telle
que nous la connaissons là où il y en a
pas aujourd'hui et s'assurer que s'il ya
un jour une sorte de cataclysme sur
terre la vie continuerait certains
voient en lui un milliardaire fantasque
d'autres un visionnaire hors du commun
elon musk est aussi un libertarien qui
apprécie peu les réglementations sur
twitter il veut instaurer une liberté
d'expression absolue aucun filtre au
risque de laisser des messages racistes
ou de fausses informations se propager
le commissaire européen thierry breton a
prévenu le réseau social devra se plier
aux règles de l'europe et poser des
limites le rachat quant à lui devrait
être effectif d'ici la fin de l'année
alors c'est intéressant sur le débat
déjà commencé pendant ce reportage elon
musk qui rachète twitter faut-il s'en
inquiéter qu'est-ce que ça va changer
pour nous âgées mais aussi pour voilà le
débat démocratique en général parce que
c'est une agora trt devenue très
importante j'accueille asma là bonjour
bienvenue vous êtes spécialisé dans le
politique du numérique et enseignante à
sciences po nicolas vanbremeersch
bonjour et bienvenue fondateur de
l'agencé spin tant que plaignant du
cercle de réflexion renaissance
numérique julien pilot bonjour ou
bonsoir il y avait aussi bon soir ou ce
soir professeur d'économie et stratégie
numérique à l'école de commerce inseec
avec nous toujours matthieu croissandeau
évidemment éditorialiste politique à mes
côtés et olivier lascars qui est en
duplex rédacteur en chef du pôle digital
de sciences et avenir
et puis aussi à venir la recherche
auteur d'une biographie des laudes musk
l'homme qui défie la science publié aux
éditions allisio s'asseoir en juin mais
c'est déjà disponible en précommande non
je commence avec vous tient olivier la
scarpe lots de masques l'homme le plus
riche du monde de fortune estimée à 270
milliards de dollars est ce que l'argent
est son principal moteur
non non l'argent n'est pas son principal
moteur elon musk c'est quelqu'un qui a
une vision de l'avenir
futuriste qui a alimenté par par sonner
lecture de sa jeunesse un c'est
quelqu'un qui a été élevé au biberon de
la science fiction que ce soit les
comics la bande dessinée le cinéma mais
aussi la littérature de sens que de
science fiction parfois assez recherché
il a des références qui sont assez
pointu mask 1 vous connaissez ces fusées
réutilisable qui écoles et qui se repose
sur le sol comme la fusée du tournesol
dans tintin il va ces fusées elle se
pose sur des plateformes qui sont en mer
au large de cap canaveral ces
plateformes elles ont des noms qui
viennent de livres de la science fiction
qu'ils ont signé d'un auteur écossais
que sa mère liliane m banques ce qui est
vraiment un pape de la sf pour les
amateurs érudits de l'asm était
absolument inconnu du grand public
pourtant c'est des références dont me ce
que ce
il les met en avant c'est vraiment il a
été biberonné à ça c'est d'abord la
science fiction et le fait de se
projeter dans l'avenir et de peser sur
cet avenir à ce moment-là ce rachat de
twitter c'est un événement quand même
parce que y'a musk parce que c'est la
personnalité des lots de masques ça
c'est facile aussi c'est un événement
parce que y'a meuse qui n'a pas que de
la science fiction il ya une idéologie
libertarienne derrière qui en plus
matinée dans son conservateur programme
de light wright américaine donc à rien
de wright c'est quoi c'est une sorte d'
extrême droite américaine oui oui mais
enfin tout le camp pro trump qui en fait
a fait une opé apolitique sur le camp
républicain par ailleurs et et le vent
de panique qui est arrivé en europe et
qui fait qu'on en parle ce soir en
réalité vient pas arrêter des médias
américains qui peut à juste titre
s'inquiète de ce qui se passe parce que
ils ont un rapport à la liberté
d'expression par le premier amendement
de la constitution qui est très
permissif et qui n'est pas du tout le
même qu'on a on est en france on
évoquera n'a vraiment le digital
services active vient d'être de accès en
or c'est donc cette inquiétude hic cette
inquiétude l'un vient en fait de l'art
delà de la panique on va dire du camp
progressiste démocrate est en vérité si
on prend un tout petit peu plus de
hauteur parce qu'il ne s'agit pas de
cristalliser uniquement la question
autour de la personnalité de must sa
serai un peu alors on met le débat dure
40 minutes
donc si je lance tout de suite à des
sujets si on monte un tout petit plus de
hauteur si on prend un peu plus de
hauteur sur la question politique en
réalité la démocratie américaine est à
un moment pivot on va avoir de vision
qui vont se confronter cristallisé
autour de la question de moscou train de
masquer twitter etc mais en réalité
c'est vraiment c'est la vision de moscou
libertariennes alors avec des impacts
qu'on peut discuter en vérité il ya deux
lectures qu'on peut avoir sur son
ambition pour le pôle pour le pour le
réseau social puis après la vision
d'obama qui a fait un discours ya
quelques jours à 5 forte et qui lui plus
pour une une approche un peu hâlé
européenne sur la régulation réglementée
/ rapidement libertariens comment on
définit c'est une vision très anti
étatiste sur de la liberté quasi totale
et donc en fait ça se traduit par une
modération minimale et sur la raison que
c'est pour ça que c'est intéressant
quand on parle des des réseaux sociaux
nicolas vanbremeersch et l'aude mais
c'est aussi un geek est ce qu'il ya une
vraie culture des réseaux sociaux peut
être une culture supérieure à d'autres
grands patrons de médias sociaux est ce
que vous diriez ça ah oui oui ça c'est
sûr que il est hissé construit
personnellement il est bon et je pas son
biographe 1 il ya des ja des
journalistes plus renseignés mais il
s'est construit personnellement dans son
chemin beaucoup dans un rapport aux
communautés en ligne dans un rapport à
une sociabilité numérique comme
d'ailleurs pas mal de deux personnes un
peu les asperger il est illettré surdoué
est autiste asperger enfin il y en a
fait le coming out ou l'aveu etc c'est
un peu compliqué on sait pas exactement
jusqu'où et ça y est en tout cas il joue
de ce côté il a un qi complètement sûr
développe beaucoup il fut me voilà il il
a cédé quelques neurones à ça ça
compense bref on fait pas débat sur
l'acier
quelqu'un je n'ai pas d'info donnez moi
j'étais un peu basique intéressant c'est
un hyper stratège c'est un vrai
quelqu'un qui brise les équilibres
économiques dans des secteurs il adore
sa part une vision stratégique qui
déplace la vision de ce que c'est qu'une
fusée la voiture électrique le solaire
des séries de la dore ça parce que ça
vient d'une analyse stratégique qui
confronte qui confrontent dans une
logique où il est beaucoup sur reddit 1
et beaucoup dans des forums de
discussions etc c'est un grand fan de
discussion où on va dans descendants des
communautés de manière très profonde
dans les sujets sains sur le sujet le
plus pointu du monde est des communautés
génial sur manitou est l'inversé c'est
un mouvement centrifuge est pas
centripète ça va coûter la puce
centripète m'a dit t'es senti fuji vous
avez des communautés dingue donc ils
passent des nuits sur reddit à discuter
ils se confrontent il nourrit des
visions stratégiques et puis réfléchit
de manière assez forte et il adore sa
présentation après l'osé une case lépi
créé afin de casser l'école ils jouent
pas ils jouent pas le jeu dans matheron
habituels auxquels l'ap à cette parole
policier
ça avec
avec des talk shows
dans des talk shows conservateur et ça
je ne sais pas c'est pas un alt wright
et conservateur s'est il est plus
compliqué un peu libertin
et j'essaie de reprendre la main la
dimension politique
sur l'aspect business avec vous julien
pilot si on regarde lempire d'elon musk
alors il ya tesla évidemment il y as p6
on l'a évoqué twitter on sait pas encore
mais ça ça va être signée nora link on
parle d'un plan cérébraux il ya the
boeing company alors là c'est notamment
il ya la loupe et ces tunnels pour
révolutionner le transport souterrain
est ce que le fait j'ai un pied haut de
posséder twitter c'est aussi un atout
business pour ces autres entreprises est
ce qu'on peut dire ça en tout cas on
peut l'imaginer sans aucune difficulté
puisque quiconque détient un réseau
social qui pèse 330 millions
d'utilisateurs actes alors je disais 220
millions alors les types parce que c'est
pourquoi pourquoi il ya 2 il ya deux
sources voilà ce que parce que sur les
330 millions d'utilisateurs de twitter
inscrits dans le monde tous ne sont pas
monétisable comment cela que sur twitter
il y à tout un tas de contrer
anonymisées qui se connectent de façon
très sporadique
il ya aussi beaucoup de bottes de romo
un petit robot à l'udc qui réagissent de
façon très algorithmique en fête ses 50
ans bignon à peu près ça peu près à peu
près et donc finalement tous les
utilisateurs de twitter ne sont pas
money sable en cela qu'ils ne sont pas
toujours confrontés à un écran
publicitaire qui permet derrière à
twitter de gagner un peu d'argent pour
beaucoup est donc effectivement lorsque
vous maîtrisez une caisse de résonance
aussi importante que twitter
internationale qui pèse très lourd dans
les échanges qui est très influente on
peut imaginer que ça peut vous permettre
aussi de pouvoir gagner des influences
de façon à obtenir à mettre la pression
sur les pouvoirs publics parfois pour
obtenir des choses assez intéressantes
pour votre business notamment dans la
question des voitures électriques ou ou
ce qui concerne space x donc c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut garder quand
même dans dans un coin de sa tête ce
n'est pas forcément sur une twitter que
elon musk peut éventuellement gagner de
l'argent de façon très directe mais plus
se servir de twitter pourront gagner de
façon indirecte sur sur d'autres sur
d'autres secteurs matériaux j'ai une
question très basique est-ce que ça les
vaut on sait qu'il va débourser 44
milliards de dollars y compris au dessus
de la cote n'est
pas rentable on est bien d'accord
il est rentable froid une année sur deux
années il faut faire attention parce
qu'effectivement twitter a été rentable
sur deux exercices et puis là les
données aux exercices ont été
effectivement déficitaire le dernier en
date d'ailleurs été faiblement
déficitaire parce que je pense qu'on
parle d'un bénéfice à un déficit de 200
millions à peu près en revanche l'ebitda
de twitter est plutôt en progression
alors il faut expliquer ce que ses
habilités financières auxquelles un
investisseur peut s'attendre et là pour
le coup tout est plutôt en progression
et c'est peut-être davantage qui est
recherché par ces c'est intéressant de
voir les deux comparé twitter aux aux
principaux médias sociaux réseaux
sociaux en nombre d'utilisateurs actifs
à travers le monde c'est évidemment
facebook femmes état qui est en tête
avec près de 3 milliards de milliards
910 millions youtube ces deux milliards
cinq cent soixante millions ensuite sont
à what's app tik tok snap chat et
twitter avec seulement entre 200 et 300
milles on est on est parti sur sur 200
milles nicolas g d'humains et votre nom
je suis désolé vendrait mersch
vanbremeersch c'est tout simple vendre
marche c'est pas compliqué à dire voilà
nicolas vanbremeersch est-ce que ça
allait vous je reprends la question de
mathieu oui vous pouvez vous laisser
aller voir moi je pense qu il n y je
pense qu'ils ne serais je pense pas
qu'il fait il va sur twitter pour
valoriser ses autres participations je
pense qu'il y va dans la stratégie
habituelle qui l'a d'arriver sur un
secteur pour en casser les codes et les
équilibres et qu'il a une stratégie
assez y pratiquer réseaux sociaux il les
connaît ils qu il aime twitter c'est un
produit qui pratique et qu'il aime il
aime un peu qu'ils surent utiliser ça et
qu'il a une vision de où il veut aller
hanche aujourd'hui on ne sait pas quelle
est sa vision ou est ce qu'il a envie
d'emmener mais moi mon avis une
stratégie industrielle il vient la
commune est allé sur tesla ou sur space
x pour bousculer l'économie des réseaux
sociaux mais là ça les vaut parce que
meta savons plus que 50 millions 50
milliards de dollars et que mon avis il
a l'ambition pour twitter d'en faire un
nouveau peut-être pas aussi puissant et
costaud que meta mais de venir bousculer
jeu et tik tok byden someta ça vaut
beaucoup plus que 44 milliards de
dollars et à mon avis il veut faire une
culbute alors de manière très nette
olivier nass car si on si on jette un
petit coup d'oeil dans le rétroviseur
des différents business d'elon musk est
ce qu'il a toujours s qui transforme
tout en or voyez ce que je veux dire où
est ce qu'il ya quand même quelques
échecs
non il a il a des échecs ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que sélectivement son amour
pour twitter il s'explique par ses
origines entrepreneuriale a comme ça a
été dit dans le sujet après avant le
débat qui vient paypal vient d'une
mairie qui vient du monde du numérique
donc depuis la grande de paypal il a
investi dans d'autres sociétés qui sont
toutes celles que vous avez cités et
avec lesquels il a construit du dur si
je puis dire avec des fusées les
voitures en ça semble très éloigné de
l'univers du numérique mais est
néanmoins il vient par ailleurs dans ces
sociétés il a continué à avoir une
approche qui est celle des
informaticiens vous savez que les
informaticiens quand ils font un
programme le programme peut marcher j'ai
dès le lendemain il faut qu'une version
bêta et puis le surlendemain il faut une
version bêta points 1 ensuite une bêta
points 2 et à chaque changement par
petites touches il modifie le programme
de façon à l'optimiser masque il a fait
pareil avec ces fusées l'un c'est à dire
que il fait un lancement avec un moteur
fusée et puis ça marche ça marche pas si
ça marche ils leur ont fait le coup
d'après mais avec des petits changements
histoire de rogner sur les marges
histoire d'améliorer les capacités il
rendement et par une série de tests
d'essai et éventuellement de crash il va
modifier son appareillage est arrivé à
ces engins qui ont des capacités telles
qu il a taillé des croupières dans les
parts de marché des acteurs classiques
du spatial donc il a ce côté
informaticien qui l'a toujours eue dans
son business quoi et c'est intéressant
effectivement mathieu on peut regardez
aussi twitter sous l'angle politique
c'est devenu quand même à un outil de
communication quasiment un outil de
communication préférés des personnalités
politiques ah oui et en particulier dans
cette campagne présidentielle je un
exemple soudé où pendant ce débat
d'entre deux tours marine le pen a une
feuille de papier elle propose en effet
j'ai fait un tweet sur la valeur de
preuve voilà tweets sur la crimée qui a
valeur de 2,2 de documents de preuve de
sa déclaration passée c'est vous dire
l'importance que ça a pris ça a pris
beaucoup d'importance parce que on
n'aurait pas vu un phénomène comme les
mots en notamment apparaître s'il n'y
avait pas eu autant de relais sur les
réseaux sociaux il serait apparu mais
pas de la même façon n'est pas avec la
même chambre d'écho parce que c'est
twitter est une formidable chambre
d'écho politique et médiatique c'est
aussi un organe de pouvoir regarder les
débats qu'il ait pu avoir quand emmanuel
macron se servait de son compte qui
avait pourtant créé avant d'accéder à
l'elysée et les ses concurrents ont fait
un recours devant
devant les tapas pour pour qu'il ne
puisse plus utiliser son compte deux
présidents jugeant que c'était une forme
de concurrence déloyale par rapport aux
autres parce qu'il n'avait pas ça et
puis enfin c'est sur twitter que c'est
un outil de communication incroyable
qu'ont voulu faire parler de vous le
meilleur exemple est l'une des plus
grosses switaj pour moi dit twittos
tweet après au féminin sandrine rousseau
sandrine rousseau exister dans la
campagne en très grande partie par ses
déclarations médiatiques d'interview
mais par twitter elle a réussi à se
construire un personnage fédérer autour
d'elle des communautés et c'est en gros
on a une qui a fait un peu différemment
c'est marine le pen qui elle préfère
facebook parce que il ya ce qu'on
appelle de l'engagement une génération
de communautés beaucoup plus forte elle
se sert de twitter pour communiquer mais
beaucoup plus de facebook où elle était
très très majorité entre guillemets dans
tous les échanges jusqu'à la veille du
second tour alors ça pose aussi la
question de
de ce que seront les déclarations des
politiques sur twitter où des
personnalités en général sur twitter à
ce moment là il ya six si on se pose des
si on se demande ce que et l'oms va
changer sur ce réseau social pour
éventuellement le rendre plus rentable
et devenir un concurrent plus puissant
des autres médias sociaux et la sédition
de bouton modifier
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'une personnalité pourra
changer sans tweet le modifier et donc
on n'aura plus quoi là là le tweet
original c'est j'essaye de bien
comprendre ce qui peut se passer je
réponds très rapidement avec ce pack de
lait dit et puis peuvent de modification
et puis après parce que c'est une
excellente question qui fait la jonction
avec l'action précédente et en fait
elles sont liées à ce que le modèle
économique est aussi disons
organisé autour d'une pensée politique
et idéologique sur sur le rapidement sur
la question des dites aujourd'hui en
fait on quand on quand vous quittez vous
n'êtes pas en capacité de modifier
soirée modifications donc ça c'est un
des unes des cosmétiques mais disons que
peut-être que vous aurez un avis
différent mais je ne trouve pas qu'elle
cristallise quoi que ce soit d'autre que
toujours cette histoire d'être libre de
pouvoir avoir la main sur son contenu et
c'est ce qui est beaucoup plus
intéressant c'est en fait les visions du
modèle économique il a déjà annoncé et
qui sont complètement encourager salué
par jack dorsey kate et fondateur de
twitter est en fait il compte etc pour
rejoindre votre pain il compte en fait
allé potentiellement sur un modèle
d'abonnement c'est à dire que tout d'un
coup de twitter ne serait plus gratuit
et en charriant l'envers de sas et
charrier toute la désinformation les
trolls les bottes les fermes à troll est
donc tout ce que cela suppose qu'on
compte du premier parce que ceux qui
seraient intéressés pour devenir pour
s'abonner pour payer c'est ce qui
pourrait déverser toutes sortes
d'informations si au moins il y aurait
moins de modération cg c'est que c'est
le contraire c'est ce qui manque en gros
ça serait des barrières à l'entrée ou en
fait on aurait de laquelle coach
comportés parce que précisément les
fermes et rôle et c'est ça en fait à peu
de frais donc il jouait sur la viralité
qui aime jouer sur la gratuit donc si on
veut garder le twitter originel avec de
la modération fort à payer c'est une des
hypothèses est en fait derrière c'est la
vision des bertail est dans le sens où
ce faisant on abolit la question de
modération puisque la qualité des
contenus qui seront elles complètement
diffusé sur des réseaux là sera beaucoup
plus qualitatif par l'abonnement c'est
une des hypothèses et puis l'autre qui a
ôté aux cités a lancé c'est l'ouverture
de l'algorithme alors l'ouverture de
gori mais effectivement c'est quoi ces
commandes à ccc une logique on appelle
ça l'open source c'est ça julien pillot
qu'est ce qu'est ce que ça change la
hausse y faut pas être trop technique
parce qu'on s'y perd après mais
il faut comprendre ce qui est souvent
reproché aux algorithmes sur les
business on arrive au sens très large
qui se dépassent twitter c'est l'idée
selon laquelle en fait du fait de votre
liste ultra ciblage qui est permis par
l'exploitation de vos données
personnelles parfois très sensible on
arrive finalement à vous pousser un
contenu ou de vous intégrer dans des
communautés qui sont autant de bulles de
fil qui vous laissent à penser que
finalement le monde tourne autour de ce
que vous pensez on s'enferme dans son
mode de pensée dans un groupe qui est de
plus en plus restera une certaine
exactement exactement et l'idée en fait
d'ouvrir les algorithmes c'est de
regarder déjà de façon très précise
comment est-ce que ses algorithmes
fonctionne pour savoir s'il n'y a pas
une exploitation abusive de certaines
données qu'on pourrait juger comment
très sensible pour pouvoir faire c'est
ultra ciblage notamment votre
orientation politique orientation
pourquoi pas sexuel vos convictions
religieuses dans des choses qui
appartiennent réellement à votre
intimité qui permettent parfois d'aller
très très loin dans l'intrusivité dans
votre vie privée donc ouvrir
l'algorithme c'est aussi quelque part
dire aux géants du numérique et
notamment à twitter attention parce que
ce qui vous permet aujourd'hui aussi de
gagner beaucoup d'argent c'est cet ultra
ce ciblage publicitaire qui est très
très très prisée des annonceurs et là
bas jusqu'à présent c'était un petit peu
le far west avait fait un petit peu tout
et n'importe quoi en disant quelque part
derrière gorille qui a le secret des
affaires il est hors de question que
vous avez jeté un oeil à ce qui se passe
dedans voilà maintenant avec le fameux
digital services et actes qui a été
entérinée en tout cas de façon
provisoire durant le week end
l'union européenne qui va vraiment faire
des émules en tout cas petit andy
viennent je l'espère va se donner les
moyens dès 2023 de pouvoir regarder ce
qui se passe au niveau des agrumes les
rendre plus transparent pour éviter ce
alors balade m'offrez la transition
toute trouvée pour la chronique de caen
un calme mais qui étaient là juste
derrière le rideau rond soit content a
donc cette cet accord digitaux le
service acte c'était ce week-end à
bruxelles c'est ça et c'est un moment
historique thomas rien de moins il aura
fallu un an et demi de travail en
coulisses et 16 heures de négociations
ce week end pour parvenir à ce compromis
on a vu deux scieries breton le
commissaire européen au marché intérieur
se réjouir sur twitter où il y avait dit
il nous avons trouvé un accord et parler
du manager milestone faille européenne
citizen sein d'une étape majeure pour
les citoyens européens les 27 états
membres ont donc réussi à se mettre
d'accord sur un accord réfection
provisoire on va y revenir et sur une
nouvelle régulation des plateformes le
dernier règlement en la matière de
techniques de l'an 2000 ce nouveau
règlement européen sur les services
numériques s'appelle donc le dit jean
paul servais six actes ou ds à il met en
place un cadre strict pour les
fournisseurs de services sur internet
comme par exemple l'obligation de
retirer promptement je cite tout contenu
illicite c'est à dire illégal un qu'ils
respectent pas les lois des pays membres
ou de l'union européenne il oblige
deuxième point également à la
transparence des algorithmes et donc
doit permettre aux utilisateurs de
désactiver ces algorithmes enfin ces
plateformes feront l'objet d'un audit
indépendant chaque année leur
surveillance sera menée par la
commission européenne cette commission
accc a parlé d'une première mondiale en
matière de régulation du numérique
parlant d'un principe ce qui est illégal
hors ligne doit également être illégal
en ligne alors quels sont les domaines
qui sont particulièrement visées par ce
nouveau règlement eh bien les priorités
sont la lutte contre les contenus et les
produits illégaux dont on compare le
rayon de l'incitation à la haine les
produits dangereux car vendus en ligne
et ne respectant pas les normes ou
encore les contrefaçons parmi les autres
priorités il ya les atteintes aux
processus électoraux très important le
texte interdit par exemple le ciblage
publicitaire en fonction des données sur
les opinions politiques des utilisateurs
le texte se veut aussi équilibré en
notant l'importance de la liberté
d'expression les plateformes ne doivent
pas sûr censurer les contenus en fin dé
tout un volet sur la protection des
mineurs par exemple en empêchant les
messages directs d'un utilisateur
inconnue un mineur le texte se veut
ambitieux prévoyant des amendes jusqu'à
6% du chiffre d'affaires de ses
plateformes voire même l'interdiction du
service dans l'union européenne il
prévoit également des obligations
particulières commune et bien d'une pour
une trentaine de très grosses
plateformes numériques celles qui ont
plus de 45 mille utilisateurs 35
millions 1,45 million d' utiliser et
edge et et remercie tous pour votre
vigilance il ya donc des obligations
particulières pour ses plateformes en
bourse bien sûr à facebook youtube tik
tok ou encore ebay et même le bon coin
donc il reste quand même quelques étapes
1 c'est mon dernier point on le disait
un accord qui est pour l'instant et bien
temporaire parce que il doit encore être
ficelé techniquement il ya des votes
attendus du parlement du conseil des
ministres européens cela peut prendre
plusieurs mois ensuite les grandes
entreprises auront quatre mois pour
mettre en oeuvre tout ses règles les
plus petites le feront en 15 mois fin
2023 ce règlement pourrait donc être
totalement effectif merci beaucoup quand
un explication très complète sur ce
digitaux le service actes à ce moment là
elle est ce qu'on pourrait dire que
l'europe est en train d'inventer la
révolte à la régulation du numérique
inventé par les par les américains mais
moi je les formuler autrement
juste pour vivre sur le dos et ça c'est
vraiment une avancée pour le coup
symbolique politique et bultex
globalement dans en tout cas dans sa
philosophie plutôt très bon et c'est une
avancée est en fait il vient de quoi
d'une stratégie défensive concernant
notre souveraineté numérique ou plutôt
de la perte de la souveraineté
technologique ont enregistré jusque là
et donc notre dépendance extrême dans
nos usages au bik texte qu'on appelle
les grandes plateformes tech américaine
et de ce point de vue là finalement ce
qui était défensive jusque là devient
finalement l'europe par son retard est
en train d'être en avance d'une certaine
façon avec ce texte c'est hâtivement
incroyable comme quoi il y avait pas de
fatalité et et surtout quand on est bon
sur la norme quoi on est très bien et
obama lui-même dans ce fameux discours
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure en fait le
camp progressiste démocrate et une
partie du champ académique américain
regarde de très près ce qu'on fait en
termes de réglementation vraiment et le
dsa et le dma aussi qu'ils sont jumeaux
sur la question de l'antitrust sont très
regardée en fait part par une partie des
décideurs américains mais juste pour
revenir sur le dessau de la 2d des
mesures qu'on pourrait qu'on pourrait
détailler qu'on a détaillé ce qui est
très intéressant tout d'un coup c'est
que par ce texte on territorialise les
biftecks c'est à dire que tout d'un coup
et c'est que c'est à dire les géants les
géants du handi numérique en
l'occurrence les réseaux sociaux et en
l'occurrence donc twitter c'est à dire
que vous avez une obligation de
respecter la réglementation européenne
et qui elle-même renvoie au cadre légal
national et donc chez nous l'ensemble
des contenus illégaux quitte avec
modérés qui sont encadrés par la loi n
181 le code pénal et c'est un nicolas
vanbremeersch est ce que ça veut dire
que les craintes qui s'expriment déjà et
qui s'expriment vous le disiez tout à
l'heure aux états unis sur le les
risques d'une prise de contrôle de
twitter période musk peut-être voilà une
espèce de 2,2 euros de boîte de pandore
ouverte encore un peu plus grand sur la
haine en ligne cc minoré en france grâce
à cette loi européenne enfin ce texte
européen
glory suis là vraiment en europe
le il ya toujours des risques
parce que pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
contre-pouvoirs sur un certain nombre de
pouvoirs de censure que pourraient avoir
ces deux lots de masques à ce stade
il pourrait décider de couper le micro
ou le tweet le twitter à certaines
personnes pour l'instant il n'a pas de
garde-fou de contre-pouvoir de fait
n'est en inverse il peut aussi peut
décider d'en réintégrer par exemple de
nice où il peut décider d'en réintégrer
à ce stade et ceram et ça ça concerne
beaucoup les etats-unis penchent
effectivement en france l'eau peut il
opéra il est déjà soumis à la mgen
loi pour la confiance dans l'économie
numérique est déjà soumis à des lois un
twitter est déjà en bataille dans des
dents des dents des dents des sujets il
ya déjà des réclamations des obligations
de modération etc il y en à venir mais
c'est déjà le cas en europe c'est déjà
aussi de coeurs aux états-unis - mais
quand même aussi et c'est donc il n'y a
pas deux il n'y a pas de sentiment de
far-west d'impunité ça n'existe pas on a
beaucoup imaginer que ils auraient tous
pouvoirs pour tout faire et c c'est pas
vraiment car évidemment il a plus de
pouvoir parce que ben il vient et puis
il peut faire un peu ce qu'il veut mais
il a aussi matinée d'intérêt économique
et de régulation assez forte et je pense
que le dessin va s'imposer et la
concomitance des deux montres à chemin
intéressant ça peut pas être le seul
chemin de l'europe parce que si on veut
regagner la souveraineté technologique
il faudra qu'on est con remonte par en
bas notre écosystème industriel pouvoir
technologique on a perdu la bataille des
réseaux sociaux on n'est pas opérateur
de ça donc il va falloir qu'on qu'on le
gagne on ne peut pas faire que la
régulation mais cette régulation une
fête à jouer 1er gp dès qu'on avait
faits sur la cgt demande générale sur la
protection des données fait inspire
beaucoup beaucoup d'autres régulation
dans le monde entier et ça c'est quand
même une force c'est quelque chose
d'intéressant et on progresse dans ce
monde j'ai posé une question de béotien
mais j'ai du mal à comprendre le concept
de territorialisation de twitter qui va
contrôler d'où je me connais par coeur
qui va conforter ma nationalité c'est
l'adresse ip comme ailleurs c'est
l'adresse ip oui l'anonymat n'existe pas
assez d'enseignants succès du fait de
niveaux on sait parfaitement vous
identifiez vous géolocaliser on sait
parfaitement qui vous êtes en rectifie
un succès ceux qui insultent sur twitter
le savent pas forcément
dans la rue le sol français
aura un tweeter différente d'une
collection sur le sol allemand est
par ailleurs indépendamment de huy et la
gendarmerie d'ailleurs c'est le far où
la police les différents parquets mais
surtout c'est à dire que twitter en fait
on a l'impression que c'est un réseau
mondial et c'en est un mais en fait il
était autorisée du jeu par l'action de
la langue et de la culture vous parliez
des présidentielles la campagne
présidentielle française qui a eu
beaucoup lui aussi sur twitter sur des
réseaux sociaux mais en réalité ça
concernait le microcosme franco français
pour la langue par la culture par
l'agenda national etc donc on sait de
toute façon d'une part les règles
s'appliquent à facebook et twitter
instagram pour la campagne électorale
prend pas les mêmes qu'en colombie où
quand agen cordes et ça pour moi l'art
comme l'art comme c c'était le csa avant
et maintenant c'est l'autorité de
régulation à la fois médias audiovisuels
et médias sociaux type de l'artiste n'a
pas beaucoup de moyens donc la question
de faisabilité
c'est une vraie bonne question olivier
lascars je reviens vers vous peut-être
pour savoir comment se comporte le
patron elon musk dans ses autres
business vis-à-vis des réglementations
c'est intéressant il la tesla hilare etc
il se il se plie aux réglementations
c'est quelqu'un qui a du mal à se plier
aux règles 1 on l'a vu en d'autres
occasions
sur le sujet du duc au vide et il avait
utilisé notamment twitter pour
critiquer les règles du confinement il
comprenait pas qu'il ne puisse pas
ouvrir ses usines au texas il incité ses
ouvriers a continué à venir y travailler
donc il a beaucoup de mal avec les
règles et d'ailleurs on voit
qu'aujourd'hui le mur sur lequel il est
en train de se casser le nez c'est le
mur législatif parce que ces entreprises
d'un point de vue technologique
elle arrive à un certain raffinement
technologique s'est pas encore
complètement opérationnel vous voyez que
la voiture autonome il rêve il promet
qu'un jour il y aura une voiture
autonome une voiture qui vous l'aura
tout seul on sait pas encore le faire il
sait pas encore le faire mais c'est
quand même assez perfectionné il ya
cette entreprise n'aura ligne qui a été
citée tout à l'heure n'aura ling c'est
une entreprise dont l'objet est de
constituer des implants de construire
des implants à mettre dans le cerveau
qui permettront de contrôler des
machines par la pensée ça paraît
complètement et c'est fait futuriste
mais c'est un champ de recherche qui
existe depuis des décennies et bien
avant musk jusqu'à présent on utilise
des implants cérébraux pour traiter des
maladies par exemple la maladie de
parkinson il ya des personnes qui sont
équipés comme ça de petits implants dans
le cerveau qui permet d'envoyer des
influx électriques qui vont contre et
les influx produit malheureusement par
le cerveau de ces personnes et qui
génèrent les tremblements des membres
donc s'annoncer déjà le faire ce que dit
mme peu ce que c'est que demain avec les
implants de novalink une personne en
pleine forme pourra être équipée et
pourquoi pas jouer aux jeux vidéo par la
pensée or aujourd'hui il n'y a pas un
cadre légal qui permettrait à meuse co
états unis de faire ces expérimentations
sur des personnes saines
donc là on touche du doigt la
problématique de il a besoin finalement
s'il veut continuer à avancer sur le
chemin qu'il s'est tracé il a besoin de
lois à sa main en quelque sorte et c'est
là où le projet c'est mon n'est plus
dans le projet c'est là où le rachat de
twitter peut avoir le sens de soft power
qui a été évoqué au début de ce débat
c'est à dire que en devenant une sorte
de citizen kane du numérique parce qu'on
compare beaucoup mais ce cas iron man
lettonie star et ses références de super
héros mais il était en transe surtout de
joueurs selon elle c'est citizen k il
s'est hissé
construit il se construit un empire
médiatique et d' influence considérable
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce sont les réseaux
et c'est le numérique qui joue ce rôle
là donc en ayant cette force de frappe
il va avoir l'oreille des politiques il
va avoir les amitiés qui lui faut pour
peut-être demain avoir un étal dans nos
états unis qui lui permettront d'aller
au bout de ces expérimentations alors on
va continuer on l'a déjà évoqué mais
aller un peu plus loin autour de cette
idée liberté d'expression ou business de
2,2 la haine écouter ce camp ce qu'on
dit julia cagé l'économie du yaka g7 et
ce matin sur france inter plutôt
inquiètes de ce rachat de twitter par
elon musk masquer leur achète avec un
certain nombre de 2,2 dans vie de
modifier le fonctionnement de ce réseau
social notamment ils leur achètent titre
de ce qu'il appelle la liberté
d'expression il faut quand même leur
contextualiser un tout petit peu ce qui
a marqué l'histoire récente de twitter
c'est le bannissement à vie de donald
trump suite à la prise du capitole du 6
janvier 2021 et là on a vu finalement le
rôle joué par les réseaux sociaux
twitter
facebook comme instrument finalement de
propagande et de mobilisation de la part
de l'ancien président étasunien et donc
on a vu le danger des réseaux sociaux
face à ça les réseaux sociaux ont réagi
on est bon on va bannir donald trump
parce que ça lui donne trop de pouvoir
il y avait 80 9 millions de followers de
donald trump sur twitter et la meuse que
dit non twitter est un lieu de liberté
d'expression toutes les expressions
doivent pouvoir s'exprimer sur twitter
c'est à dire y compris celle d'un donald
trump qui nierait par exemple la
validité des résultats électoraux et
c'est pour ça finalement ça prend le pas
sur celle là julien pilot si on élargit
si on sent un peu twitter et qu'on pose
la question des réseaux sociaux ou des
médias sociaux mais en général le la
haine c'est un c'est aussi un business
quoi çà çà çà si vous voyez ce que je
veux dire si si c'est vrai c'est
peut-être un peu binaire se le dire mais
si ces réseaux sociaux ne dépense pas
beaucoup d'argent sur la modération
c'est parce que ça leur rapporte or
jusqu'à il jusqu'à un certain point
jusqu'à un certain point et là on va
faire peut-être un peu de prospective
sur ce que pourrait devenir twitter
c'est vraiment l homme est ce qu'elle
est au bout de son idée mais
effectivement pour les raisons que
j'expliquais tout à l'heure avec ses
bulles de filtres qui fédère des
communautés et qui parfois les jettent
les unes contre les autres bon bah ça
crée évidemment de l'engagement ça crée
beaucoup beaucoup d'interactions et
cette interaction ça fait des vues et
s'est vu ça génère des revenus
publicitaires parce que ça crée de la
pression publicitaire donc évidemment
que ça rapporte il n'en demeure pas
moins que ya une vieille loi qui est
bien connu des économistes appellent à
loi de gresham du nom d'un banquier
britannique du 16e siècle qui dit que la
mauvaise monnaie finit toujours en jeu
c'est la bonne ce banquier la 10è avait
analysé que dans un système où
cohabitent et deux monnaies qui ont
chacune en cours légal finalement la
monnaie de la moment d'au moins bonne
qualité va finir par chasser la monnaie
de meilleure qualité simplement parce
que les coûts liés à son utilisation
soit inférieure parce qu'à moins de
contrôle d'accès etc et une fille nés
les agents économiques finissent
toujours par arbitrer massivement en
volume en faveur de la mauvaise monnaie
plutôt que de la bonne et ce principe en
fait on peut l'appliquer dans beaucoup
beaucoup de business et notamment dans
l'est dans les business de type réseaux
sociaux je l'appliqué moi même dans une
série de travaux de recherche et
effectivement on se rend compte que
pour des raisons qu'ils ont assez
similaire à ses plus jeunes d'évoquer il
arrive très fréquemment que finalement
une certaines
monnaies finissent par chasser des
utilisateurs qui sont 2 leur qualité
parce que plus nuancé et parfois parce
que plus monétisable on peut répondre
par exemple l'exemple de facebook mon
facebook a commencé à se démonétise et à
partir du moment où finalement les
populations peut-être les plus nuancée
mais également celles qui sont les plus
jeunes ont commencé à sortir d'elle-même
du réseau parce que finalement on y
trouvait plus en compte retrouver plus
d'informations intéressantes et puis
c'est pas très sympa d'être sur le même
réseau que grands-pères et grands-mères
en fait et en fait sur twitter imaginons
qu'on aille jusqu'au bout de la démarche
des landes musk si au final vous en tant
que personne nuancé vous devez besoin de
dinde un thread d'un fil de discussion
de 10 tweets en 200 caractères pour
pouvoir exposer mes pensée complexe si
mme finné vous retrouver en phase de jeu
ouvrir des guillemets b de trolls des
cavernes qui viennent juste pour vous
insultez vous allez vite on partir de 8h
et in fine et qu'est-ce qui pourrait
rester si je fais un petit peu de
prospective finalement les gens qui ont
une utilisation professionnelle de
twitter et puis ensuite les personnes
aient moins modérée d'ailleurs qu'elle
soit du côté d'un côté de l'échiquier
politique ou de l'autre d'accord oui
c'est effectivement une analyse
intéressante brouillé intervenir ouais
c'est déjà un peu c'est déjà un peu le
problème de twitter aujourd'hui twitter
et se monétise mal et c'est un endroit
centrifuge un endroit où de convergence
est un endroit des espaces publics
d'affrontements de communautés où il
reste des médias des journalistes des
communautés qui se rassemble et qui
s'affrontent et qui perd en intérêt de
ce point de vue là et qu'ils retrouvent
de l'intérêt régulièrement au sein de
liberté intéressant lors de la hongrie
en ukraine et à personne n'y a aucun
autre espace pour fabriquer ce que
twitter fait en termes d'information
d'émergence et de cerner avec le modèle
du grain noir à tout cela on y trouve de
tout on y trouve information
voilà du relevé ça qu'on arrive pas donc
qu'ils acquièrent une fonction très
forte et donc moi je pense que la
modération il va la retrouver il ya
aucun endroit qui n'est pas modéré il ya
aucun les et les rares espaces qui ne
sont pas modérés qui ne sont pas
organisés qui n'ont pas des règles et ça
sont des espaces horrible et ses deux
consoeurs culture et ça n'est pas ce que
musk à pois pour envie parce que il à
200 et quelques millions d'utilisateurs
actifs chaque jour qui sont utiles qui
sont beaucoup en europe et pas aux états
unis en très large majorité et donc il a
envie quand même qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient actifs il alors j'ai envie de les
concerner d'intérêt mais je gardais une
dernière question pour olivier lascars
parce que il faut quand même se la poser
est ce que l 'on losc a des ambitions
politiques d'ailleurs est ce que il y
aura chez twitter peut-être sur sa rien
pour se présenter à la prochaine
présidentielle américaine
je pense pas qu'il ya un projet
politique personnelle de la part de
meuse qu il est trop focalisée sur ses
propres entreprises et sur le devenir de
ces profs d'entreprise par contre je
pense qu'il va développer comme j'ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est connexions
politiques ses accointances politiques
on a vu dans le passé sa proximité avec
trump qui était une proximité parce
qu'ils allaient tous les deux dans la
même direction quand trembles a été
président il a exigé de la part de la
nasa que la nasa organisent le retour
des astronautes sur la lune alors que la
nasa était parti plus tôt sur un
scénario qui visait à construire une
station spatiale un petit peu comme la
fameuse iss mais à en orbite de la lune
et la tremblade tapé du poing sur la
table en disant que lui et ce qu'il
voulait c'était qui est des bons hommes
sur la lune puisque évidemment sa part
l'été ça lui permettait de devenir le
président du du retour sur notre
satellite ce faisant il a permis de lire
la conclusion de witte d'avancer à
marche forcée sur son propre vaisseau le
starship non l'intérêt de musk sur la
politique c'est quand la politique lui
permet de faire avancer cette vie qui
dans son business d'accord sur qui se
présentera lui c'est d'abord ça merci
beaucoup olivier lascars elon musk
l'homme qui d si la science et le titre
de votre livre qui est publié donc au
mois de juin aux éditions allisio est
disponible en précommande merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat